un petit tour maintenant du côté de
l'hôpital de la milétrie à poitiers pour
voir comment sur le terrain justement
sont utilisés ces fonds reportage
christophe de vallans bras et philippe
ritaine la petite alice est née il ya
quelques semaines prématurément
depuis elle est suivie dans ce service à
l'hôpital de poitiers chaque jour ses
parents sont auprès d'elle pour la
caresser lui parler on voit très bien
que la lys sans notre présence
lorsque l'on arrive n'y a pas de
problème c'est un bordeaux très
important c'est vrai quand on a un
contact privilégié quand on est sur
place alors que s'il en était 100 km 100
km le couple habite beaucoup trop loin
pour faire la route tous les jours alors
l'hôpital a mis à sa disposition un
petit studio dans la maison des familles
notamment financées par les pièces
jaunes un centre d'accueil dans
l'enceinte même de l'hôpital tout près
de leur petite fille là on y va trois
quatre fois par jour on y reste le temps
qu'on veut et puis éventuellement
comptant le surgelé les cités où on peut
toujours sortir mais c'est vrai qu'on
est très proche d'elle la présence des
parents est primordial pour la qualité
de vie des enfants hospitalisés
mais il est aussi très importante de
pouvoir se détendre un peu s'amuser à
poitiers la fondation des hôpitaux de
france à aider à équiper un espace
adolescents avec un billard un baby-foot
quelques ordinateurs aussi et internet
ça aide
saran le séjour pis-aller ça passe le
temps mon moment
je m'en parlait du monde de l'extérieur
ça cust ont atteint notre préoccupation
c'est d'abord l'accueil et le soin donc
nos investissements se font pris
directement dessus et c'est vrai que la
partie animation côté ludique pour les
enfants et quelquefois un peu masqué
dans nos investissements et la fondation
des hôpitaux nous permet de répondre à
ces petits plus qui font la qualité de
vie d'un enfant à l'hôpital avec la
préoccupation qu'un enfant reste un
enfant malgré l'hospitalisation et la
maladie et c'est parfois bien difficile
par exemple quand il faut demeurer
enfermer des jours durant dans une
chambre stérile
grâce aux pièces jaunes l'hôpital a
acheté quelques ordinateurs portables
une aide précieuse pour alexandre
celi permet de faire autre chose que de
regarder lança cendres longueur de
journée l'avant nul ce sont des êtres
qui permettent aux patients de mieux
supporter l'hospitalisation le
traumatisme de l' isolement qui dure
souvent en quatre à cinq semaines
les ponctions tous les soins qui sont
quelquefois un petit peu difficile et
donc ce matériel détourne l'enfant ou de
l'adolescent de la dure réalité du
traitement en 12 ans les pièces jaunes
ont subventionné plus de deux mille
projets pour rendre un peu plus
supportable
le séjour des enfants à l'hôpital